he's Joe Vardhan he covers the Cavaliers
for cleveland.com the Cleveland Plain
Dealer and kind enough to join us before
he takes a flight back to Cleveland
what was that catice locker room last
night postgame um well the last two
games here in Boston were quiet that's
for sure
just kind of a lot of you know by the
guys out there trying and and
contributing a lot of just kind of be
into themselves and staring at the floor
and then there's a back row guys the
younger guys who either aren't playing
or not playing well and they kind of
have days looks on their faces so you
know there's a rough two rough couple
days these guys out here how is this
spun in Cleveland's favor in any way
well you know Boston hasn't lost to
anyone at home in this postseason
they're 9 I know now they play much
worse on the road I mean you've got the
simplest most sophistic sentence and
sports that rings true you know the Cavs
have LeBron he can turn a series he can
turn a game they're coming back home and
this team you know isn't what it once
was they don't have Kyrie Irving
obviously but it is an organization that
thrives in chaos rise when times are
their worst they've already faced
elimination once this year so you know
you just got to go back to Cleveland and
win your games that that's all you know
it's it's not they don't need to make
this bigger than it is if Cleveland goes
down three Oh does the spin then become
where what LeBron's offseason plans are
or is next stop yeah and I mean I think
it does I mean we already the the thing
is you know in that Indiana series we
were happy and we were having that
discussion in in print you know on
television I mean because it was it was
tenuous
you're looking at a first round exit and
that would just be unacceptable to
LeBron in any way shape or form you feel
better I guess overall I think I guess
about him and his future just because
they've gotten this far but as he does
his mass as he does his homework you
know he's going to look at this roster
as is and if they don't make it out of
the Conference Finals against the team
that was missing two of his best players
that's that's not going to bode well so
sure as soon as the Celtics hit three in
this series whatever that is that's that
you go right back to that conversation
do you think Boston is going to win um
well I mean I know it's I know what the
numbers are
it's an outrageous stat about winning
the first two at home and going on so I
mean I sure but but I just want to see
the Celtics take one of these two games
and cleaver before I can go there I mean
I guess this is my fourth year left on
this beat I showed up on LeBron did and
he's just taught me like not to declare
him dead until until there's you know a
mountain of evidence to do it and I mean
they were down 300 finals and I know
it's a different team but they there's
nothing he can't do so you know I game
threes in Cleveland and you know the
series is still there for the cats to
get in this and give it her up talking
to Joe Vardhan the Cavs beat writer for
Cleveland calm Cleveland Plain Dealer
house LeBrons health well I think he's
okay you know these days I mean that's
you know the kind of a blunt force that
he took to the jaw there from from Jason
Tatum up which was on accident that
would knock a smaller man out I think
and it definitely shook him you know
Tai suggested after a game that that
actually had affected LeBrons play
afterwards you know LeBron disagreed and
I don't know how true that I was and he
still scored 17 in the second half with
six rebounds and six assists and I think
the Celtics made it harder on him it
made maybe being dazed slowed him down
enough for them for the Celtics to catch
him but you know LeBron took 29 shots in
Game two and and 28 of them were
contested hmm so you know all that work
he was doing the first half whether he
got smacked in the jar or not I mean
that just that's gonna wear you down if
every time you shoot the ball is
somebody's hands in your face if you
were LeBron would you stay with this
team I mean that is a great question and
I appreciate the way that you did you
put it just because I think that the the
discussion can be more about basketball
you know you can talk about legacy and
which i think is intact
either way but but there would be some
PR hit if he left again and you know
that he's not very 34 I don't know if he
wants to deal with that again his boy is
gonna be in eighth grade is all the Sun
next year so he's almost in high school
and he's old enough that both of his
boys have friends like they they may
want to stay northeast or they may not
they may want to move to LA where they
have friends to you know Savannah his
wife all her family's in Northeast Ohio
the whole crew so you know the
basketball calculus isn't great I'm
gonna write this later today the Chad's
actually have to fix this they have some
components to move around and get
another guy in here but I don't know you
know I think the Rockets are learning
this the hard way I don't know that you
can put together a team that can be
taken
the lawyers so this LeBron want to rip
his family out of Cleveland to go
somewhere where he's not going to anyway
I mean maybe he might but you know I I
don't know it's it's hard I said you
asked me if I would leave Cleveland if I
were him I get I mean I don't know
because like because like him I'm from
Akron we won tweets that we lived on the
same street
I guess I would say I would stay but but
I get it I totally get where he is with
this and you know I understand the
allure of living somewhere warm and and
being it just in a different situation
and maybe get an all-star to come listen
and you see so wait you lived on the
same street as LeBron yeah I I found
this out the day before the 2016 game 7
we had a discussion we've you know we've
known each other doing this job and and
you know we talked Akron every now and
then but there's a section of North Hill
in Akron that's like the best one of the
neighborhoods there and the street is
Woodward Avenue and it's kind of a long
street but you know I'm four years older
than him roughly and and and there was a
time where he was moving around like
from house to house and and he stayed on
Woodward Avenue and me and my family and
I we stayed there and then you know he
probably moved somewhere else
he was you know living somewhere else
but every six months and then we moved
to the suburbs and it's just kind of
crazy how you know the paths cross
however many years later but yeah
Woodward Avenue a national model you're
probably not gonna be living on the same
block same street as LeBron anytime soon
I'm guessing Jo right no a safe travels
back always great to check in with you
Jo thank you for spending time jo
Vardhan Cleveland Plain Dealer
cleveland.com for more dan Patrick
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]